morgan wallen will not perform this week
on saturday night live the rising
country star was cut from the lineup
after tick-tock video showed walton at a
crowded bar
in alabama not following covet 19
protocols
this is the video of him not following
those protocols
fans on instagram that he has fans on
instagram say that he hasn't tested
positive for the coronavirus but he
feels bad
for letting them down my actions this
past weekend
we're pretty short-sighted i respect the
show's decision
because i know that i put them in
jeopardy
so that's his heartfelt apology uh and
you know it's
it's a good apology but let's hope it's
lessons learned but you see why they're
doing it they're being so careful to
keep
everybody safe they want to keep that
show on the air and in the studio
and i mean he acknowledges he said i
think i have some growing up to do
he was very contrite yeah he wasn't
thinking so who doesn't have him back
yeah he's a young guy
we all make mistakes we'd like to see
him come back we want to see him come
back and it's true
anthony snl is showing you what good
behavior looks like
and there are consequences